- Can we check out the
bling you are wearing?
- What bling?
What are you talking about?
- [Kelly] What are you talking about?
- I don't know what you're talking about.
- [Kelly] I need some sunglasses!
(laughter)
Nice!
It's nice!
- Thank you.
- So have you met before?
I don't think you've met yet.
- No, we haven't.
- No, how are you?
- Okay.
- Well, we're well.
- Very nice dress.
Nice to meet you.
- Nice bracelet.
- [Kelly] It's so pretty!
- Thanks!
(laughter)
- That was not--
Watch out, she's a klepto!
- Don't let the dress fool you.
(laughter)
- So you also like in your
special you talk about
dating a lot, so I just wanna
know like what kinda woman
do you look for?
Just for everyone out there, maybe--
- I like all women, yes,
(crowd screaming)
I like, hey girl I see you over there.
I see you, hey!
(clapping)
(laughter)
- You like all women, no one
specific, nothing specific?
- [Deon] I like older women
too, older women that's, yeah!
(cheering)
I see you, I see you.
- So what is it about older women?
- I don't know, man.
- You got mommy issues?
They got it together.
No, they just got it together!
(laughter)
If you got a chain on
the back of your glasses,
I'm coming after you, I promise.
(laughter)
Oh, there you go!
(cheering)
- That's Iowa!
That's Iowa!
(laughter)
I mean, it is like we
planted Iowa in the house!
- Iowa girls are not shy.
- Iowa girls are not--
You know neither are Texas girls!
I would have a drink with you ma'am.
You are fun!
(laughter)
You just had a birthday right?
- Yeah!
- So what is it like getting older?
What do you, what are you thinking?
- I don't know, it's
just weird getting older.
I kept thinking something was
on my eyes for the longest
when my eyebrows had grew
all the way out here.
(laughter)
I was like man I can't see up.
So I never shaved my eyebrows
and trimmed them down,
but now I have to.
So.
(laughter)
I know it's like this!
It's like you rang?
(laughter)
I gotta do like this.
Hey!
What's up Kelly?
- [Kelly] Like comb it,
you're combing it back?
- Hey Kelly, how're you doing?
(laughter)